oh my god wait a minute oh you're just
wearing an engagement yeah I put it on
to try it on and decided it felt so good
and I didn't want to take it off there's
only a few weeks left before we do get
married so no I can't come on because
I'm trying to keep it low-key and I'm
sure nobody would show up but they might
what kind of nuptials do you have
planned is it gonna be intimate big
hometown destination intimate and
hometown correct they're low-key
low-maintenance we're both kind of
introverted people for the most part so
we don't want we don't like celebrating
ourselves too much if there ever is the
time to do it it's now and it's more to
celebrate the union of marriage than it
is each other and I'm excited about
doing that with you tonight yeah yes it
means you guys to be able to finally
step out together after everything
you've been through it means a lot
because this change in lifestyle happens
when the two of us weren't weren't
dating it together so I'm sort of been
introducing her to my new life a little
bit at a time over the last six months
and this is a big leap compared to some
of the small steps we've taken so far so
I hope she enjoys it it's a radical
change for sure but she's optimistic and
I'm proud that she's out here with you
tonight yeah so far she looks gorgeous
and you know she's feeling good smiling
so that's a good sign how did you know
that it was the right time to propose
it's just that bit feeling you have that
heart radar that guides us in life it
just starts tapping on your shoulder
when it's time and you just make a move
so that's what I did
[Music]